this morning on the ditch a man who's
brought artisanal French baking to
countries around the world
born in Lorraine France eric Kaiser's
great-grandfather grandfather and father
were all traditional French bakers in
fact he learned to count by preparing
eggs and measuring sugar he worked as a
baking teacher and consultant and then
in his early 30s opened his first bakery
in Paris it was an instant hit and led
to Maison Kaiser locations all over
France and then the world today there
are over 100 bakery cafes in 20 nations
from Tunisia to Tokyo including 16 here
in New York City
Eric Keizer good morning welcome to the
dish this is a terrific spread tell us
what's here so I tried to come in with
many many different type of food that we
serve in our place we are starting with
we go in with pistachio and found on
shockula after we have the torch you see
this big tour that we use it's very old
recipe and we put Salman and cream
inside so you can serve the food and eat
directly you don't need to clean the
place and water you have the famous
boeuf bourguignon that you can take for
lunch of dinner in our place and after
you have the salad salad with some
leaves and Robshaw and it's something
very good with back wheat bread and
after we have a raspberry tart and we
have different of dish you see if you
for example we show how we can do a
baguette with with goat cheese goat
cheese because very simple but very good
we try to go back to find the good
ingredient on the top of the bread so it
means that we mix we try to take care of
the brain and on the body yeah it was
very important if you if you had pure
before you have a good brain it's true
she's normal aware and bread it bread
makes me think better I know that yes
chef
that you're using artisanal heritage
technique your family was involved in
boulogne trees bakeries but they sold
the bakeries before you actually began
your stint as a baker tell us about your
family history yes my family has a
bakery a smoke between east of France
and when I was very young since three
years my dream was to be a baker and I
see in my dream that I will traveling a
lot and open a bakery in different
country so when I was 16 years I
starting to learn the bakery for two
years we say upon visage after I was at
Jeremy and after I do the Tour de France
but not with bite for bicycle for
running for learning bakery for five
years and after I've starting to teach
to the people how they can improve a
technique for the bakery right and after
eight years I decide to open my first
between 1996 you were throught one Wow
yes and my dream was to starting to do a
bakery my my my bakery in Paris but in
the some time try to teach it to the
people how they can improve this works
is business because battery is beautiful
you know you take five ingredients I say
that I'm flour water
so do sourdough salt and passion and you
do something fantastic tell us about you
talk about around the world
you have businesses around the world you
have business in Tunisia in Tokyo you're
in Cambodia you're in Senegal how how is
how do you have quality control when you
have so many places around the globe in
such different market yeah different
market I think the most important is if
I am alone I am nothing but because I
have a team I try to to to give the
know-how to my people and my some people
are better at me now so they can take
care of the Quietus this is the most
important to give you know how to give
your patient to the people and after
they can take care of the quality you
were in the blue berets yeah and you
served in Lebanon yes which was part of
your whole sort of desire to see the
world yes yes and I think I have
starting to learn how I can live with
the people in this time you know cause
you sleep in a tunt you stay for six
months so in a town you share your food
and all and you're starting to learn how
you can share with the people and this
is it was a very important part of my
life in terms of sharing information
have you changed different pastry
recipes or products depending on each
market that you're in yes
for example in Japan they love matcha
tea so we put we add matcha tea inside
the almond croissant and the people just
love that but for sure we need to adapt
the size for example in Japan they like
small size in America we could choose
the bigger size since we are starting 20
years about 1 in 2 years ago we are
starting to reduce our sugar half of the
quantity in the past 3 Wow this is the
most important for me
what that makes me all the more eager to
eat this Eclair twice as many because it
half the sugar chef as I asked you to
sign this Davis I will pose the question
we always ask which is if you could
share this beautiful meal with anyone
past or present who would it be
I think I will take my gun batter
because she give me the technique and
the patient to do something very good
and it was she was very important for me
to give me to show me the way well it
she has shown you the way this bread is
beautiful I'm going to eat far more than
I possibly should Eric you guys there
chef thank you messi beaucoup thank you
very much 24 more on Eric Kaiser and the
dish head to our website at CBS this
morning calm